[Music]
most people
are good some people are bad
but you you're the rare gift
so get in and get out
you could always think on your feet
anyway not so much tonight
we sent away so many prematurely
either by my hand but through you
we never sent anyone away who didn't
have it coming
but we all have to pay for our sins
eventually
[Applause]
[Music]
meet your downstairs
[Music]
she's not gonna run she's gonna lick her
wounds and she's coming after us
someone killed a friend of mine because
of a contract he completed years ago
oh yeah
you could be answers i'll be the last
thing you ever seen
why don't you just consider it a mystery
best left unsolved you know
that i'm no good
you keep this up you're gonna die
i just wanted to end their life
and anyone standing in my way
[Music]
you're intrigued by her curious
give us bad manners no
i'd really like to see you again under
different circumstances
these are the best circumstances you'll
ever see me in
[Music]
you